besides the rattlesnake did you ever
think you're in a situation where you're
like all right this is it i'm done
uh
sure i mean when i got credit by wild
boar i don't know if he's going to give
me some hallucious infection it's going
to kill you about three days later
he's got all these diseases
and also the blood he got an argument
had to hold it like this i was bleeding
out like there's no tomorrow trying to
stop the finally coagulated and stopped
but you're bleeding out and i'm thinking
okay i need to go to clinic and get
antibiotics or the next day i took
antibiotics everything i never got an
infection but yeah when the alligator
bit me in the back that's another thing
you get bit by now i didn't get an
infection but you just put 12 scratches
on my back if you ever had got hold my
arm he would have tore off he got me in
a bad angle
so he bit the wetsuit and slid the
wetsuit
away from me so he put like 12 scratches
on my back and a bruise here so he
wasn't able to get a good
you know
more like this that type of bite gotcha
did you see a good grip on it did you
see recently i'm not sure where it was
but it was some uh alligator handler
like uh it was was was bitten and and
the alligator got her yeah the girl and
the alligator got her hand and one of
the tourists like jumped on the
alligator and saved her and it was
rolling like
what do you think when you see that
and she kept her hand and she's very
very fortunate that kept her hand
because once he bites he does this the
hand comes off what happened she went
under she wasn't careful enough to get
the hand way underneath here
yeah you know that's my specialty always
going to i never got bit by an alligator
confrontation
you keep that hand low and make sure but
if you're not paying attention it goes
in
go get it you gotta put it here i took a
guide diving one time and he's swimming
on the surface like his mask was all
[ __ ] up i picked up an alligator up
alligators at his mouth open i was
underneath him and i go
in the water i gotta swim in and put his
hand right in the alligator's mouth
the guy ping ping ping ping ping but a
bunch of like look like bullet holes all
in the hand that's the only guy i ever
took out there they got bit by an
alligator wow
first aid bit yeah but why didn't the
why did the crocs go after you like or
the alligators on the on when you're
climbing the rope with like they just
went after the meat why wouldn't they
just because i think they they they were
expanding with her i think what it was
was that those crocodiles are captive
they were fed chicken like constantly
like they're used to the chicken like so
when you present them with chicken
that's what they want that's what
they're going to go for and yeah if you
give them a chicken and then you take
your chicken with put your hand he'll
take your hand but the the chicken being
the closest to him my calculation was
that we're going to grab the chicken and
miss stevo's butt that's one of the
funniest [ __ ] things manny ever said
he says and it's in the movie it says if
an alligator gets a hold of stevo stevo
will relax
and hopefully the alligator will release
him
for sure
like that guy when he got bit in a hand
i knew it was under i said i just backed
away from the alligator and i was hoping
the elegant alligator released and swim
back into the bottom of the
quarry
alligator fighting man he says relax
relax and pray yeah yeah
unless you're getting eaten alive you
know it's a different thing but normally
if you're messing with an alligator and
he bites when he has an escape route he
may let you go
if you've got a good grip on him and you
got him on land or something like that
but he's got deep water to let go he may
let go and take off in the deep water if
not he may never let you go it's called
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole and
if you go on amazon and type in stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're
ranked number 30 on all of amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on amazon and buy stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude